♫
>> AMERICA IS BACK AND WE
ARE COMING BACK BIGGER AND
BETTER AND STRONGER THAN
EVER BEFORE.
AND WE’RE MAKING OUR OWN
PRODUCT AGAIN.
[APPLAUSE]
AND WE’RE OPENING UP OUR
FACTORIES AGAIN.
AT THE CENTER OF AMERICA’S
RESURGENCE ARE THE MASSIVE
TAX CUTS THAT I JUST SIGNED
AND IT’S ALSO REFORM BUT I
USUALLY JUST SAY TAX CUTS
BECAUSE THAT’S WHAT
PEOPLE -- THEY DON’T WANT TO
HEAR ABOUT THE REFORM.
BELIEVE ME THE REFORM IS
VERY IMPORTANT.
WE DON’T HAVE TO GO INTO IT.
BUT THE FAX CUTS ARE THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT TAX CUT,
MOST SIGNIFICANT REFORM IN
AMERICAN HISTORY WITH
TREMENDOUS TAX RELIEF FOR
WORKING FAMILIES, FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES, FOR BIG
BUSINESSES THAT PRODUCE
JOBS, FOR JUST ABOUT
EVERYBODY.
TREMENDOUS NUMBERS.
AND YOU ARE ALREADY SEEING
WHAT’S HAPPENING.
AMERICANS DO ANYTHING, BUILD
ANYTHING, AND CREATE
ANYTHING AS LONG AS WE HAVE
PRIDE IN OUR COUNTRY,
CONFIDENCE IN OUR VALUES,
AND RESPECT FOR OUR GREAT
AMERICAN FLAG.
[APPLAUSE]
RIGHT?
BECAUSE AMERICA DOESN’T
BELONG TO THE WASHINGTON
POWER BROKERS.
IT BELONGS TO YOU.
AND I THINK WE HAVE TAUGHT
THEM THAT.
[APPLAUSE]
DOESN’T MEAN IT’S EASY.
IT DOESN’T MEAN IT’S EASY.
IT’S NASTY IN WASHINGTON.
BUT STEP-BY-STEP BY STEP.
JUST KEEP GOING, RIGHT?
GOING, IT IS A NASTY PLACE.
GETTING IT NOBODY THOUGHT WE
WERE GOING TO HAVE THIS KIND
OF SUCCESS SO QUICKLY.
>> AMERICA IS BACK.
WE HAVE NUMBERS TO PROVE IT
THAT WAS THE PRESIDENT’S
SPEECH FROM EARLIER TODAY IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
JOINING US WITH REACTION FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR TOMI
LAHREN.
2.2 MILLION NEW JOBS SINCE
THE ELECTION.
WE HAVE CHRYSLER MOVING FROM
MEXICO TO MICHIGAN, THAT IS
HUGE.
AND THEN, OF COURSE, WE HAVE
CARRIER AND ALL THESE OTHER
COMPANIES.
THEN WE HAVE GOT MASSIVE TAX
CUTS, WHICH IS GOING TO
BENEFIT 90 PLUS PERCENT OF
AMERICANS.
WE HAVE.
REGULATION GONE FOR EVERY
NEW ONE.
UNEMPLOYMENT AT 18-YEAR LOW.
APPLICATIONS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT, BLACK
UNEMPLOYMENT FEMALE
UNEMPLOYMENT THE LOWEST IN
17 YEARS, HISPANIC
UNEMPLOYMENT THE LOWEST EVER
RECORDED.
THAT’S LIKE A HALF A CENTURY
UNEMPLOYMENT.
$8 TRILLION IN NEW WEALTH TO
THE ECONOMY I DON’T INVEST A
WHOLE LOT INTO IT.
APPLE RETURNS TO AMERICA
WITH A MASSIVE
350-MILLION-DOLLAR
INVESTMENT AND MANY OTHER
COMPANIES.
HOW COULD THE MEDIA TOTALLY
IGNORE THIS, TOMI LAHREN?
>> WELL, BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATS AND LIBERAL
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, THEY’RE
SHAKING IN THEIR BOOTS RIGHT
NOW.
AND IT’S BECAUSE PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS WINNING FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT HAS BEEN THEIR BIGGEST
FEAR SINCE LAST YEAR.
SINCE HE WAS INAUGURATED ON
JANUARY 20TH OF LAST YEAR.
THAT HAS BEEN THEIR BIGGEST
FEAR.
NOT THAT HE WAS GOING TO
BRING THIS COUNTRY DOWN,
THAT HE WAS GOING TO MAKE IT
GREAT AGAIN.
THAT’S WHAT HE IS DOING AND
THEY HATE IT THAT’S WHY THEY
ARE GOING CRAZY.
LITERALLY GOING CRAZY.
THE MEDIA, THE DEMOCRATS,
NANCY PELOSI, THE WHOLE LOT
OF THEM GOING CRAZY BECAUSE
THIS PRESIDENT IS WINNING
JUST LIKE HE TOLD US HE WAS
GOING TO DO.
>> Sean: LIKE EVERY
ELECTION.
RACIST, SEXIST,
ISLAMOPHOBIC.
HOMOPHOBIC.
YOU CAN’T ARGUE WITH
SUCCESS.
MY OPINION ALL THE NOISE WE
HEAR WON’T MATTER WHEN
PEOPLE ARE BACK TO WORK OUT
OF POVERTY, OFF OF FOOD
STAMPS AND THE COUNTRY NOW
PROSPERING AND WE ARE SAFE
AND SECURE.
>> BECAUSE FACTS DON’T CARE
ABOUT THEIR FEELINGS.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THIS
BECAUSE I HAVE BEEN GOING --
HAVE YOU BEEN SENDING ME OUT
TO WEST HOLLYWOOD AND OTHER
AREAS IN CALIFORNIA WHICH WE
THINK WOULD BE SO LIBERAL
WHAT I’M FINDING OUT SEAN IS
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE THAT
SUPPORT THIS PRESIDENT.
THEY DIDN’T SUPPORT HIM
INITIALLY BUT THEY ARE
SEEING WHAT IS HE DOING TO
BENEFIT THEM.
>> Sean: WEST HOLLYWOOD,
CALIFORNIA?
>> HEY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEY WANT TO MAKE MONEY JUST
AS MUCH AS YOU AND I DO.
THEY WANT TO MAKE MONEY,
THEY WANT TO KEEP THEIR HARD
EARNED MONEY AND THEY LIKE
THIS THE ’.
THEY DON’T LIKE WHAT HE
TWEETS.
THEY DON’T LIKE WHAT HE SAYS
BECAUSE IT HURTS THEIR
LITTLE FEELINGS.
THEY LIKE WHAT HE IS DOING
FOR THIS COUNTRY.
AT THE END OF THE DAY COME
UP TO MID TERMS AND
RE-ELECTION TIME THAT’S
WHAT’S GOING TO MATTER IS
THE RESULT.
THIS PRESIDENT IS GETTING
THEM.
>> SO THE PRESIDENT COMES
OUT WITH THIS FAKE NEWS
MEDIA AWARD LAST NIGHT BUT
THEN YOU ARE WATCHING THE
MEDIA AND THEY ARE TRASHING
HIS DOCTOR, THE GUY THAT’S
DOCTOR FOR BARACK OBAMA AND
GEORGE W. BUSH.
THEY ARE ANGRY BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT IS IN EXCELLENT
HEALTH.
HOW IS ANYBODY TO INTERPRET
THAT OTHER THAN THIS IS
NOTHING THIS MAN CAN DO THEY
WILL NEVER LIKE.
>> THEY WANT HIM TO FAIL AND
THEY WANT HIM TO BE ILL AND
THEY WANT HIM TO DIE U LET’S
BE HONEST.
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT THEY
WANT.
THEY ARE SO FRAWS STRAIGHTED
HE IS WINNING FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Sean: HE GOT A 30 OUT OF
30 ON THE COGNITIVE TEST.
>> IS HE DOING WONDERFUL.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE REALLY
SHOULD DO IN THE SPIRIT OF
CARING AND THE SPIRIT OF
SHARING WE SHOULD HAVE THAT
SAME DOCTOR EXAMINE FOLKS
LIKE NANCY PELOSI AND MAXINE
WATERS BECAUSE THEY NEED ALL
THE HELP THEY CAN GET.
>> Sean: SHOULD WE ADD JOE
SCARBOROUGH AND DR. MICKCA.
SEE HOW THEY DO ON THAT
TEST.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO.
SHARE THE DOCTOR’S EXPERTISE
WITH THOSE INDIVIDUALS
BECAUSE IN THE SPIRIT OF
MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS THEY
NEED FAR MORE HELP THAN THIS
PRESIDENT.
THIS PRESIDENT IS DOING
WONDERFULLY.
LIKE HE SAID, HE IS A STABLE
GENIUS.
I BELIEVE IT.
BECAUSE LOOK AT THIS
COUNTRY.
WE ARE DOING GREAT.
ALL OF US ARE DOING GREAT
AND THE DEMOCRATS ARE
TERRIFIED.
>> Sean: SO YOU ARE
OBVIOUSLY IN THE YOUNGER
GENERATION.
DO YOU SEE YOUNGER PEOPLE
NOW LIKING WHAT’S HAPPENING,
MAYBE PEOPLE WINSTON
CHURCHILL, 29 LIBERAL DON’T
HAVE A PART.
40 CONSERVATIVE YOU DON’T
HAVE A BRAIN.
DO YOU SEE A CHANGE NOW.
>> WHEN PEOPLE ARE GOING OUT
AND GETTING FIRST JOBS IF
THEY DO MOVE OUT OF THEIR
PARENTS’ BASEMENT AND
ACTUALLY WANT TO GET A JOB,
THEY WILL BE HAPPY WHEN THEY
CAN KEEP MORE OF WHAT THEY
EARN INSTEAD OF SECONDING IT
TO WASHINGTON, D.C. TO THEIR
FAVORITE POLITICIAN.